the republican national committee is
sending a warning to failed former
president donald trump
if you announce your candidacy for
president when we're trying to win our
midterm elections we will stop paying
your legal bills which of course raises
the question why are they paying trump's
legal bills which is a question we will
get to in a moment abc news reports rnc
warning to trump if you run for
president we stop paying your legal
bills let's take a look at this clip
from uh abc's good morning america with
george stephanopoulos explaining what is
going on republican leaders are
threatening to stop paying the former
president's legal bills if he announces
a 2024 run for president chief
washington correspondent john carl has a
story in john we're talking about
millions of dollars george this is an
entirely unprecedented arrangement the
republican national committee is paying
and has been paying donald trump's
personal legal bills some of these
related to his businesses in new york
1.7 million dollars more than that just
since october most recent payment we
know of more than 50 000
last month so now they're making this
threat and republicans really don't want
donald trump announcing that he's
running for president as they head into
the midterms where they think they're
going to do well yeah this is really
something a threat from the rnc quietly
said we found out about it uh that they
will stop paying his legal bills when he
or if he announces he's running for
president the big backdrop here is they
don't want him to run announce he's
running before the midterms they want to
run mid-term campaigns based on joe
biden and the economy if donald trump
announces he's running this fall it
messes with that strategy so they're
saying you do that we'll stop paying
your bills so that's the concept the
republican national committee has made
the calculation if trump announces soon
which the reports are trump is
increasingly thinking of doing because
he thinks it'll help him with his legal
trouble and criminal probes against him
if trump announces before the midterms
we will stop paying trump's legal bills
now are they making the right
calculation is it true
that trump announcing will sort of turn
the midterms into a referendum on trump
and potentially hurt republican
candidates i actually don't know the
answer to that and it would be something
we would need to study separately but
one big question is why is the
republican national committee paying
donald trump's legal bills and the best
answer i've been able to find is that
keeping trump out of jail looks better
for them that donald trump's legal
problems
uh growing conspicuously uh more than
they already have and they are already
pretty significant would make
republicans and the republican party
look bad and it might help can that or
hurt candidates rather in november of
2022. it is sort of strange how a
multi-billionaire needs someone else to
pay his legal fees but donald trump is
known for hiring lawyers and then not
paying them now one of the real
questions that has come up as a result
of this and we're going to talk about it
tomorrow is
trump's not a candidate right now
trump's not paying his own legal bills
what is happening with all those
millions of dollars that people are
donating to donald trump remember donate
to stop the steal donate to us because
we're going to do this that and the
other thing and elections and all this
stuff
what exactly is being done with that
money and hilariously karl rove the long
time republican strategist wrote a
hilarious it's hilarious in spite of
itself he's not trying to be funny but
it is hilarious karl rove wrote an op-ed
in the wall street journal saying
where is the money going that is being
donated to donald trump and it's a
fantastic question and we're going to be
talking about that tomorrow so a threat
from the rnc to trump
i honestly
whatever is worse for the rnc and for
republicans i hope trump does it and let
trump and the republican national
committee destroy each other if trump
announcing early that he is running for
president is considered bad and will
anger the rnc all the better i hope he
does it for that reason alone